promesas para ucrania el grupo de los
países más ricos del mundo el g7 en su
segunda jornada de cumbre en alemania
conversó por videoconferencia con
volodymyr selenski presidente ucraniano
en un comunicado los principales líderes
mundiales prometieron seguir ayudando a
combatir la invasión rusa
seguiremos brindando apoyo financiero
humanitario militar y diplomático y
apoyaremos a ucrania todo el tiempo que
sea necesario es la respuesta a las
peticiones que les hizo selenski este
reveló en telegram el contenido de la
conversación
ucrania siente el apoyo de los estados
del g7
gracias por su defensa y asistencia
financiera a nuestro país en la lucha
contra la invasión rusa para nosotros la
posición coherente de los países del g7
sobre las sanciones también es
importante deben seguir aumentando en
particular limitando el precio del
petróleo exportado del agresor
en otro mensaje excelente y concreto en
cinco puntos las peticiones seguridad
reanudación de exportaciones agrícolas
reconocer a rusia como patrocinador del
terrorismo
reconstrucción del país y más defensa
antimisiles a este último punto se
comprometió el asesor de seguridad
nacional de la casa blanca jake sullivan
por su parte el canciller alemán olaf
scholz anfitrión de la cumbre se mostró
satisfecho todas nuestras políticas
están alineadas este creo es un buen
mensaje estamos tomando decisiones
difíciles y esto es lo esencial para ser
duros y pensar en las necesidades del
tiempo que estamos viviendo
el g7 está formado por alemania eeuu
francia italia canadá japón y reino
unido- en este 2022 ya han comprometido
29 mil 500 millones de dólares en apoyo
a ucrania